[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
yo yo yo
what's going on
round
what's going on the legs what's up
black romance what's going on talk to me
sliding through
no doubt i appreciate it i appreciate it
the liz
craig simmons gaming black roller let me
know my levels are sounding
a bit that's a busy day
insanely busy day
game plato what's up man what's going on
they've got oh you got the lullaby on
okay what's going on she's no elite you
thought she was done then you reinstall
[Music]
gotta get some invites going
but um yeah we'll be right back
big day today then we're gonna cut this
stream thank you liz i appreciate it um
we're gonna cut this stream pretty
abrupt because the xbox one is right
after and we'll create we'll have
another live stream up right after so
it's that kind of day good for gaming
not good for content creators because
we're busy but it's fun for god to
create just a little stress kim curse
what up rainfall all the day to year all
in all the deputy haters all of a sudden
came back bunty you done no i saw you on
xbox live what's up bro no doubt so i'll
be back and get everybody in the room
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
my
say what's up to the people
[Music]
what up realm haha no doubt no doubt
dj oros clan member
formerly formally applied but now a lord
what's up
i feel like i made it i made it i made
it
you hear that you hear that
good to have you around man we have some
fun we probably i'm just going to switch
over to be honest because they're doing
some cool pre-stream stuff and i want
the people to see it then we can also
test out levels on the stream
so
let's do that
do a rough little stream
yeah they've been um showing artwork
apparently from content creators and
company approaches building teams have
changed all the way over right now i got
twitter building the team for halo 1 and
halo 2. all right cool let me know if
the um yeah i mean i think audio is a
little bit
like passengers
for twitch yeah he would disagree with a
lot of stuff that
that i'm going to say but i i think
compared to the intentionality that we
you know try sometimes exhibit you know
know we should have about you know about
building teams and how important teams
are
back then it was almost just this
studio
who
you know liked our games and came to the
company and you know then you know
snowball rolled a little faster and
it was yeah it was just a bunch of
people trying to do their best trying to
recreate the feelings that they had you
know when they played when they can't
wait for my boy
you can get pretty fast
i noticed
this lunch
i think uh cox should be happy warlocks
are getting any attention at all you're
considering how they're usually not past
jason
yeah
[Music]
what to i don't know what to make of
that because i feel like i feel like
i've learned so much but when i go back
i'm sort of like blown away by the xbox
you know it's actually going to start
yeah what was what was happening
today
technically
uh no it's pretty embarrassing when i
think about like the i mean i think
about my life in terms of decades and
like what's the what are like the big
lessons okay who says they're louder
than you guys
when i like articulate one of the like a
lesson from my theories it's like so bad
what's up give me your tags i wanted to
know what's up what stu said if the i
one not understanding
the value of having as a warlock main i
can't get down having a trailer somebody
like that
listen man he got he got a bigger
[Music]
with our ability or our dreams
incompatible with the hardware that we
need to run on
um
and i saw production as you know a
calendar and a schedule
yeah he's been working
it's true
[Music]
tracking against that
but i thought it was like an end in
itself i thought it was here they had a
lot of the streamers
pay attention to it but i mean like
embracing all that stuff is a thing that
will be yeah front and center in yeah
i think it's making sure everyone on the
team has an objective i'm pretty sure i
have a few of those
on my desktop so um
that isn't true i didn't understand that
when i started destiny one i had to get
levels destiny one made me understand
that
let's see you jump in so what i want to
talk about now is
where computers were heading mm-hmm
where's where's it going
ar is going to be the thing that
displaces mobile like i'm so i'm so sure
of that i'm so sure we're all going to
be wearing
don't ask me and do i actually like
are going to go on a landfill
all the
cracks in our ceiling are going to get
fixed in our glasses like so many people
are going to end up with virtual pets
and windows out to the taj mahal or the
something eiffel tower
yeah like i think it's gonna be a lot
sooner than that and i and i think it's
a little really interesting and when it
happens like the reason that you're
gonna know it's gonna take over the
whole world is everybody's gonna laugh
at it
like everybody's gonna think it's
you know it came out the stuff people
were saying to like not admit that they
were yeah what's going on like um
there's a rap you know chunk of the sun
in their hands that was going to change
the world like the stuff people said was
ridiculous
and and people are going to do that
and the other interesting thing about is
that better yeah
because you need high frame rate you
need to be able to render all kinds of
crazy stuff like right
there like you know without i don't know
where they are your feet are your body's
just coming into a stream i don't know
where my fellow conquerors all the cloud
communities and stuff
what's going on
but we're not going to transition to
fans i gave up i said you know what i
did everything i needed
local compute never goes once i got my
vex i'm like yeah i'm good this place is
mobile
like 100
so on a long enough horizon
how are we gonna get ready for that
we gotta forget that
yeah so there we go
i mean it's a great question and i'm
like
i think the answer is
like i
is
a way bigger tv or they're going to go
to a totally virtual space that has a
bigger play with you and they might play
some table top or straight yes that's
right
today right but i think we're
man you dig
[Music]
is
these two guys in in front of you
he loves giving money to benji you know
at first
they weren't really talking about it
keeping me going i mean that that might
fuel me for the rest of my life and it's
not the only time that's happened
but you get a few of those
you know that's all
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
what are we most excited for one minute
oh man just uh
something new that's it i want to see i
just want to see what the next new thing
for this game is going to be outside of
you know what we've been getting
about two years
[Music]
like destiny's really
dark yeah
it's some really dark lore but it's like
i hardly ever pay attention to what's
going on ever since uh
what season
i stopped paying attention
well now they're showing the story and
that's dope
wow this is actually really
dark and disturbing
i'm gonna shoot you with six anarchies
you're gonna sprint at that gorgon run
run you've got to be a little doodle run
run
what you're both excited for sir
oh my goodness having food and
hopefully
they probably won't but maybe my boy uh
rasputin will make a return
shout out to pacquiao he said you ready
for the hunt to kill osiris
y'all guardians
oh here we go we're celebrating our
journey with you whether you joined us
30 years ago
just started today
this game is in our blood the destiny
team is full of destiny fans folks who
came here because destiny was their
favorite hobby folks who log out from
work in the evening and log in to play
with their clan the team we have today
is committed to relentlessly upgrading
this game that we all love we aren't
happy with just another mission instead
we want to push the limit of quality you
can expect in an action mmo with
uniquely destiny experiences like
expunge and presage we are committed to
delivering the best mission content that
you can play in any game with a friend
and having the best feeling action game
period
[Music]
and this shows through in the passion
that we see for destiny 2. since we
declared independence two years ago the
destiny community has lost a lot you get
in my field bro you can't do that new
players and it continues to grow faster
than we ever could have predicted
we're grateful to be a part of this
amazing growing community that you all
have created
you represent destiny you've helped make
it better every year and you are so
welcoming and supportive of every new
guardian
and only a handful of us are going to be
up here today
most of them are in their homes at their
desks working hard the next part
it's a huge honor representing such an
incredible team and introducing the next
chapter of destiny 2.
so
without further ado
the witch queen oh get goosebumps let's
go
let's go
i'm feeling away
[Music]
armor looks nice
oh chicago
is a funny thing
does it live in the world
or in the mind
is it constant
or can it be bent
who decides what is true
in this universe of light and dark
there is no greater power
oh tell me
[Music]
wow
okay
i
you know what she's been doing this
whole time yeah oh my god she's gotta go
she told me this is serious i think
she's the most dangerous villain we've
faced yet seven years we've been
building up to this moment and she is
finally stepping into the spotlight and
showing us who she really is
what we know about light and darkness is
proving to be way more complex than what
we previously thought there are so many
lies truths and revelations that we're
going to get to in the witch queen and
the year leading up to it i mean we're
paying off these narrative threads that
go all the way back to destiny's
gorgeous we're supporting it the best
content that destiny has to offer
definitely and we've got a lot of
awesome content to show today let's
start with the most mysterious
destination yet
sabbath dunes throne world this is an
uncharted wonderland of secrets and
lives it's this place that she's created
in her own image the surreal and
majestic light blessed world she has
this castle that she rolls from it
overlooks this dark swampy underbelly
with this lone pyramid ship out there
it's the future world she wanted to
create built atop the darkness that she
left behind in throne worlds they're a
deep part of destiny lore powerful
entities create these pocket universes
and when we're there we have to play by
their rules but now our own light powers
are being used against us i mean she has
this whole army of hive that she's
ascended to the light and brought along
with her
these are the hive guardians and they
are the backbone of her new army
we've talked a lot let's show a little
let's take the first ever look at the
witch queen gameplay
all right all right
hive god of cunning and lies
after the death of her brother oryx
[Music]
sabathune went into hiding feel bad
not out of fear of course
but out of strategy
in her greatest trick yet
stealing our most sacred resource
the carl better not get the lights
the lights
no
this is disrespectful this is the
straight disrespect
they're gonna they're gonna make a side
of it
[Music]
just to reach out and just crush a hive
ghost in my hand yeah i mean we've been
defined by the light for so long this is
uncharted territory for us i mean we're
in strange new places like the throne
world is
haunting but it's gorgeous it's
beautiful there's a lot to love there's
a few things we saw on the trail that we
haven't talked about yet savathun and
her lucent brood this is the biggest
threat guardians have faced yet so we
need to find new weapons to match their
power yeah it's crazy right yeah the
glaze
i love this thing it's brutal and
elegant this is new energy
and defensive capabilities it's our
first ever first person melee weapon and
it is such an awesome tool for the
battlefield
every weapon designs being secondary
the glade feels so good
just jump in and unleash brutal melee
combos and transition right to an energy
blast
it's really powerful and has a lot of
utility so we've told you about what the
glaive can do
now let's talk about how you're gonna
get your hands on one these weapons
don't come out of chest at the end of
missions and you're not gonna find one
roaming around the throne world
your first glaive is not going to be
found it's going to be built yes weapon
crafting is coming to destiny
we've added more deterministic paths to
get the roles that you want on guns
think things like umbral engrams and the
raid chest weapon crafting unlocks the
freedom to choose all that and more it
gives us ultimate control over the guns
now this is a combat focused crafting
and progression system that means the
more you use these weapons the more
objectives you complete with them the
more you'll level them up and the more
powerful they grow over time and at
launch here's the awesome thing you'll
be able to craft all throne world
weapons new raid weapons and the
seasonal weapons there's just a ton of
stuff to do in this system and the witch
queen is just the beginning of weapon
crafting we have plans to add more
weapons both legacy and new throughout
the year
we've seen we've talked about a lot of
really cool features but let's get right
into the meat of it let's talk about the
witch queen campaign that's kitty
i
love cancer
they've always been a cornerstone of the
destiny experience they're rich deep
stories
big combat sequences and memorable
characters they take us to remote worlds
in our ever-changing universe and so
we're putting extra care into the
campaign for the witch queen we want you
to feel those goosebumps when you step
onto the throne world for the first time
and come face to face with hive
guardians
and every one of the missions has its
own unique fantasy like what does it
feel like to storm a castle or just go
straight into the depths of hell if you
like games with standalone campaigns
like doom titanfall 2 god war and halo
then the witch queen is for you
they throwing themselves in the mix
oh they know themselves in the mix so in
addition to a classic normal mode
legendary is our tougher aspirational
version of the campaign where the
enemies hit harder difficulties
you might tap out but if you persist and
you get to the end your time will be
well rewarded whether you want to play
solo or with a fire team the difficulty
will scale based on how many people you
bring
before we go one last trip down memory
lane i remember camping out the predator
for destiny 1 because i just had to have
the ghost to me it was like the symbol
of destiny
and if you care about that stuff like me
you're going to want to get your hands
on the collector's edition because
you're going to get a high buddy today
there you go dj
they spoke to you they knew they coming
for you throw your money at the screen
now all right how big is it where's my
credit card there you go
[Music]
yeah you better have that ready
[Music]
wow that was so cool i'm so i'm so
excited for this one and that's not even
everything that's in there too i know
those are the hero items and they're i
think one of the best ones that we've
ever done
collector's editions have always been
like this really perfect jumping point
to enter the worlds that we build and
actually lifting like in-world objects
and putting them in players hands is
just it's a good thing random items
everything in there means something and
it helps push the narrative and there
might be some puzzles to unlock in there
as well
all right i need two
one for both sides of the desk exactly
so at this point you can see sabathune
has been one of our greatest threats
operating behind the scenes for years
you may have heard of her brother the
taken king but savathun is the most
dangerous being we've ever faced she's
cunning elusive she works in the shadows
so in a way sabathun is new to all of us
exactly and now it's time to finally see
this legend reveal herself and change
the destiny universe forever
but when we talk about the overarching
story of destiny we don't just mean the
plot lines or characters that feature
released release narrative is a guiding
force in destiny and we're calling on
its rich history of world building
bringing that to the forefront and
blowing it in a bold new direction
so when you join the game might be the
last time an immediate
during this past year we watched the
results of your actions play out across
destiny's seasonal releases you've
redeemed old foes brought former enemies
to the bargaining table learned that
there's always more than one side to
every story and built alliances no one
ever thought possible and on the largest
scale you'll experience a fast moving
interconnected story that's driving to a
greater end we need you
i like that armor you'll experience this
alongside a massive community of
guardians release after release together
this is our universe's cosmic purpose
this 10-year journey we've been on since
destiny 1. it's drawing to its dramatic
dammit they got me back in the game
[Music]
we're building not so much to an ending
but more to this transformative moment
for destiny 2's future last year we
announced the witch queen and the
following expansion lightfall and now
we're excited to announce the release
after light
the final chapter in the light and
darkness saga
destiny 2
the final shape
it's going to be one wild continuous
ride yes and that ride starts with
season of the lost not only is it the
prologue to the witch queen it's your
first opportunity to interact with
sabathune but
rather than spoil it for you 50 years
old
a ring of spears pointing inward from
the edges of our system
must uncover whatever secrets she knows
with the time that we have um scream
that means two separate people
[Music]
two queens meet two separate people not
to say first yeah i think it's time to
bend the knees
and guide my people back to me
enter the shadow realm again okay there
is a malevolent force
making the zoom city relevant yeah
[Music]
your
[Music]
back
[Music]
perhaps with them i can save us all
really that's interesting yeah it's very
okay
let's get it oh
we're reaching the end of one journey in
the beginning
days of our lives
one of the changes i'm most excited
about are the updates to the light
subclasses every season in year five of
destiny 2.
similar to stasis we'll be starting with
a void subclass update that goes live
alongside the witch queen but the witch
queen is only the beginning of what's to
come and season of the lost is the
prologue to that story
it starts off with marisov's return to
the dreaming city and with her return
all the awoken technology comes alive
but the hive god of war zebra wrath has
re-emerged and had guardians and mara
and her sights guardians must forge a
path through the ascendant plane to save
mars lost which is before zebra wrath
can reach them and to aid you in this
task you'll have the wayfinder's compass
the time is at hand
it's an ancient awoken artifact that
gives the wielder the power to uncover
pathways secrets and treasures within
the ascendant plane
there's a plethora of new weapons coming
including a suite of legendary thesis
guns that will stop your enemies
oh yeah that's oh it's a 180 too the one
armor makes you feel like you're a
member of queen mars court and no season
is complete without new exotics and
season velocity features one once
intended for aldrin
let's take a moment to talk about trials
let's get it so try
to be in-game aspirational pvp activity
and more popular than ever two of the
biggest ads from our community i've been
adding antique sheet and adding
matchmaking and seasonal lost we're
doing both let's partner with that
software when trials goes live on
september 10th wow
you'll be able to match make with groups
of players to form fire teams or solo
queue by yourself yes oh bro
weapons and coolest armor in the game
that's right we're shifting away from
winning matches as a primary way to earn
loot and instead of winning individual
rounds and completing matches would
allow you to earn some rewards but going
flawless hasn't changed so if you want
to flex those pvp skills the flawless
chest will still be the only place to
earn except charles weapons
that was a big deterrent it was it was
all right so the next chapter
begins right after this match
returned to the dreaming city with
marisol and learned the mystic art of
wayfinding i'm so excited cross play is
going live today
[Music]
cinematic
yes 30 years it's been a good ride
why are they showing master chief for
the
destiny streams
[Laughter]
listen man
this is why we play this game
yeah man
oh they get me y'all gotta stop [ __ ]
getting the motions
all the play testers playing halo yeah i
remember these videos 60 days bro
um
halo
and their significant others and their
communities and those who are in need
it's pretty devastating as we look at
the
racism the miracles
our intention is to do better and to
leave the world in a better place we
want to be a part of that social change
[ __ ] racism
we don't just stop with the games that
we make but we really utilize the
successes that we've seen to be able to
give back in an even greater capacity
that spans beyond just the gaming
industry
foundation thank you
[Music]
pressing button we're live
[Music]
alright
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
no paid
[Music]
a meal
[Music]
oh nice transition look at that
nice transition
[Music]
how do you follow that wow oh we got
some hey ladies
that's some halo music i remember when
halo first launched and my friends and i
completed the entire campaign in a
single epic play session and as the
credits rolled i knew that that bungie
had transformed council gave me forever
friends and that
together so we're going to have a party
in destiny 2.
starting this december we are launching
the bungie 30th anniversary celebration
in destiny 2 december 3 for all players
the 30th anniversary celebration will
offer a new six player matchmade
activity
secrets to unravel and rewards our long
and storied history together and that's
just the beginning in addition to the
free event players can also purchase the
bungie 30th anniversary pack that
includes
three-player dungeons
yeah cosmetics to collect including
ornament sets inspired by the third
anniversary celebration and marathon
halo anniversary song
galahorn is making its long-awaited
debut
during the bungee 30th anniversary
celebration but the party isn't only
happening killing this goddammit
we've made over the years and a sneak
peek
[Music]
yeah i mean
look at all the games and products that
have come out over these years yeah
starting operation desert storm pathways
in the darkness
marathon that's why halo's coming out
this year
caleb they are not missing that release
date
you know we have a lot of really cool
stuff coming up and a lot of other
things in the works of course as always
but yeah i mean what do we have we have
the fallen captain statue which is
incredible and then we have the helmet
the celestial knight thing is so cool
arcadia
yeah i get goosebumps
i think it's a great way to we're going
to sell you all donald trump
heritage but the seven year heritage of
destiny yeah and it definitely gives you
the feels
they just know how to cut things
together man oh right
you're looking at all the detail that's
for king that's for king
yup oh that's definitely
buying that
thank you for being on this journey with
us
this year
30 years ago we just started talking
about the witch queen today you've got
our first peek at weapon crafting our
definitively destiny campaign the glaive
and a year full of updates to all our
light-based type classes all of this and
more is coming alongside savathun's
long-awaited arrival front and center to
the destiny universe
the witch queen marks an acceleration in
our story heading towards the conclusion
of the light and dark saga and we're so
excited for everyone to join us on this
epic adventure in the witch queen
lightfall the final shape and beyond
ambient the witch queen's gonna kick off
another amazing year of destiny with
four great seasons packed with all of
the narrative events and rewards that
you've come to expect from us but
there's even more coming next year than
just our new seasons
the deluxe edition of the witch queen
will also include
two brand new dungeons to be released
and we're also going to be remastering
another classic
and releasing it free
this means going forward starting this
december 30th anniversary
there will be a new piece of raider
dungeon content in the game every three
months
okay in 2022 we will also be adding
legacy rotations for rage and dungeons
every week there will be new ways to
earn rewards in both the latest this is
what we want we can raise for
if you love amazing in-game content we
want to prove that no other game offers
more quality and more variety than
destiny 2.
we hope that you've enjoyed a look in
the future of destiny
which queen pre-orders is far available
and season of the lost kicks off today
see you in game oh we'll have fun at
xbox live stream goodbye
wow
truth is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
prepare for what is inevitably to come
i think she's using osiris to have mara
tells people to wrap the other system
that doom finisher right there
yeah
that was a really good finisher with the
eyeball
really yeah oh forgot about like five
minutes before i have to end the stream
but um because we got xbox up but what
the hell did that was about that that
was amazing that was absolutely amazing
yeah like
they killed it they killed it every
level on every single level and you know
what i'm going to just say this i just
want to say shout out to you especially
paul for getting me to join the ilp you
know i love since you already know ever
since i joined i've been able to do a
lot of stuff that i hadn't before like
raiding regularly
doing these grand masters getting my
conqueror title and now i'm excited to
uh experience all that with clan iron i
can't i'll be in the building you
already know what it is
yo that was fire y'all
dj where where we at what you thinking
bro uh it's amazing dreaming city coming
back that's that's i'm ready for it it's
it's time so we're good we're good forte
where we at bro
and i've been telling people for years
that every time budgie does some trailer
like this reveal like that it
really galvanizes the whole community
and makes everybody just remember all of
the great things about it and the fact
that we know expect that they they truly
listen to us just looking at this they
listen to everything that we wanted and
me being a person people wouldn't know
that i'm a true pvp main in this game
trials having oh i forgot about that
there's so many news i forgot about that
like like like for me it's like
everything else is good like i look like
you don't have to course taz into coming
out here with what's happening
but we still gonna be going in there
because i think it's just gonna be it's
just gonna be more than amazing
if i can see these i just can't be
averaging way more people now did it
everywhere
oh i i'll come back
like i'm more like i'm gonna get you
know
get tired of like playing the one-shot
corner sniping [ __ ]
and like now it's like they go ahead and
tea bag and it's just like man come on
now now there's going to be you know
some form of of matchmaking i feel like
there's going to be a lot more people
without willing to jump in there yeah
shout out to philly eagle twitter iop
class standard this is an iop clan
stream this is actually a clan stream
this is fine what did you think alex
real quick if i pass the dev just about
the other announcements pve and all that
like wait are you are you hyped for this
giant yeah well it's zap of thumb
you know how i like i was i like i liked
the last expansion but i was
disappointed it wasn't sad bethune
remember right
it's like i've been waiting for this man
like the taking king is my favorite time
in destiny actually i feel like this the
way that they're describing it it feels
like this is going to be another task
yeah you feel the build up like you feel
it def where we at bro like
let me say one more again you know we've
gotten arguments a couple of times
throughout the years about
how
bungie doesn't like make new enemies
they just re interact with the enmities
they currently have they did that in
this one but i'm willing i'm willing to
give them a pass on this one because
this isn't just let's let's make let's
make the throw i see you throw a fire
you like they gave me they gave them my
bills
like when i did that blade
what i saw that night throw a shield i
was dumb
bro
that's a crazy cause of death where you
at man all the years the stream how you
feeling bro
i love bungie and
everything but as a big mmo player the
whole weapon crafting is straight fire
because i love going around collecting
stuff forgot about the crafting so much
the trials
a part of this game again yes the deep
dreaming city coming back one of the
most beautiful places shout out to oh
lord zero the original og ilp tell us
some chat been taking a long break happy
to jump back in when the queen is
arriving and i'll actually give trials a
fair chance now cheers to being to it
being accessible yeah that's a huge the
barrier the barrier yeah i think that
that was the missing key because it's
like you know we want to play trials but
i mean look we're okay destiny pvp
players but like since it was so
you know
it was it was the the king it was home
to nothing but sweats nothing about
those people that go to the lighthouse
18 19 times the time then you got the
twitch community doing characters
and then so so then you're dealing with
them too and then not to mention
trials is gonna get better because the
pool is gonna the population is gonna be
crazy
right we ain't gonna have to deal with
the sweats all the time because there's
so many gonna be it it's it's gonna be
huge okay if i let you find then i'll
get my balls off and then we gotta end
it up because i gotta get the extra and
then my girl cellophane looking so so
good
unbelievably good and i can't when she
started flying that was pretty big i
really can't wait i really can't wait to
put her in the ground with the birdie
oryx
already already
well i mean
we have to finish the family line
there's one more sister left
i mean kill the entire family you know
what it
i have a is that
when we kill sabathune the third sister
is going to become stronger than both of
them combined well will she survive
because then zebra wrath going to be in
this the seat of the loss today right
yeah
i mean she was in a couple seasons ago
and lived through that so
i don't think they'll kill her in a
season like that that's a high gall like
the thing is you can't she because when
she's the god of war right essentially
so
i'm assuming she'll probably come in
like lightfall or something when she
comes with her entire army and just
declares war and everywhere and if i
remember correctly
they used to be one entity so when you
kill one the remain that power is split
between the remaining people yeah i know
shout out to stitch being messy two
little chests so are we killing osiris
hope so
so i got a
question pretty much um basically a
prediction they're not prediction well
what do you guys think about this what's
up we know
destiny became very very popular on xbox
when a certain thing happened a game
pass last year oh yeah yeah do we think
that that is do we oh yeah yeah
yeah which queen is going to be in game
pass day one yeah you want to say
something no i'm just hoping it's a game
pass day one yeah yeah i think it's
going to be they'll buy the collector's
edition anyway though
the mentioning of bungie i mean of halo
the 30th anniversary them showing halo
vividly keeping that connection i think
this is they're not going to be bought
but remember what i told is but
microsoft bungie is friends with
benefits like they are still
casually hanging out you know and so i
love it i think that's what was going on
date and cologne find out some chat i'm
more pissed off the fact that the
notification for this stream just
dropped on me so i have a lot to watch
and you know we got we got to take a
moment of silence
because the gala oh i forgot about how i
forgot about the galley on this street
that's how much info was on this stream
so here coming in december new pirate
theme dungeon
thorne inspired armor set bungie themed
ornaments and cosmetics for the budgie
site
yeah claymore soar from myth
and more let me just look real quick
we've got probably like five more
minutes for industry and i believe they
said the callahan would be part
specifically of the events so you have
to participate in the event i think
together oh yeah okay
well make sure you participate
all right cool because yeah this this is
crazy man oh man look at that armor on
the second one man i'm wearing that i'm
wearing that
so so attic i gotta ask you does this
mean you're gonna be on destiny day one
and not trying to cram everything
together in the last week of the season
no i'm still doing that
i'll jump on for a couple weeks when it
first launches
but then after that it's a wrap like
this this is crazy yeah throwing in fear
wow
and then keep in mind we we got we got
our playstation brother like jabari in
them over there on on on
on playstation i'd always be talking
that smack like i would be cool to set
up some private uh that's what i'm
saying
versus the playstation nation no doubt
they stay i wish i had that what was
that that that that wrestling no chance
in hell oh yeah
no
yo crazy stream said i got it but look
at this it's a new dungeon and raid
every three days every three months of
december i forgot about that yeah that's
crazy then the legacy content they man
they they're on fire they literally even
got a big list
maybe the reason that the the because
they said they had they hired more staff
more developers and stuff you sure you
want to end this you sure you want to
end the stream cognito you sure xbox is
going to leave them to our expectations
we don't have the night look man
i really don't care if xbox messed up i
don't either
it's cogworld i got it i got what i want
someone hit me up and they're like are
you going to do a spaces today for xbox
i'm like no no no
playing destiny
i can't
i can't believe that i got to go back
because i'm a big like reaction person i
like watching reactions i got to go back
to some of these reactions when i get
out yeah
it's like because that was so it was
that wasn't leaked like at all a lot of
this wasn't like yeah like i got front
i got emotional during this stream like
two times like mad emote like they were
killing it with the fields killing that
[ __ ] memories yeah that chick was crying
when she saw like remember how when you
start destiny 2 it shows you like all
this stuff oh i remember yeah
everything you did in one and you see
all these names that you haven't played
with in like years yes all of a sudden i
actually beat it with the squad yeah i
see some people who passed away that was
part of that journey too it was crazy
but oh yeah they absolutely killed it
the content launched the narrative
aspect the campaign difficulty um i like
that because usually let's be real story
campaigns are very easy you blaze
through it that kind of thing they they
all they're firing on all cylinders nine
out of ten man yeah that's probably the
best stream they've ever done
it is literally literally that's the
dangerous
stream in like general that we've seen
from from any corporation in the last
couple years yes they hit every note and
every highly requested dream item
they've hit like dream stuff would be
like budgie would never anticipate would
never bring gallagher and brag bungie
would never like everything we like yo
magical they did
i'm like
because it's a busy day xbox is up but
yo do your shout outs real quick dj
orals formerly clan play pleb now clan
ilp a lord he has risen tell the people
where they can find you sir
oh i'm here and you'll just find me on
xbox uh playing destiny uh all day today
all day tomorrow you know the next few
months here so thank you thank you
little brother you already know
my man forte what's going on bro
yo man
man can we find you
forte gaming for everywhere about to
head over to um slow mo's channel so we
can do this upstream
he dropped this on me on the day that
destiny came out i said oh god i would
have been like sorry i don't speak
english yeah
i i texted what time is this stream he
said one o'clock i said oh my god long
day bro all right yeah so it's a long
day man but yeah check us out um on
youtube
needles they just started just starting
yeah we got three yeah we got two other
things
the ashen one the newest conquistador
we're gonna find you what's going on sis
yeah you guys can find me on twitter at
the ashley luca or youtube at the ash
and luca also on xbox live at the ashen
luca or a playstation at lucy quinn all
my stuff is in my um
twitter profile so if you you know oh
i'm also on steam as well at the ashley
lucas you know uh shout out to uh gg
sinister and obama for uh
for uh you know being the main ones
mitaz and nautical are playing with when
it comes to uh these raids these grand
masters shout out to them and uh you
know dj orals man we gotta get it in bro
we gotta get it in it's gonna happen
wait till they bring that that that
orange right back oh so yeah yeah yeah
yeah it feels
they said oh yeah perfect talk about the
best rated destiny
you're right you're right this is your
phone
talk y'all talk i'll let you i had this
this is yours
this is y'all
look like the king's fault not to
mention like they're telling us all this
new info
and when the which cream drops her
raid's gonna drop with it perfect setup
perfect setup like everything's lined up
for them man i care for death telling
people where they can find you man
what's going on
all right you can find me at desinger
literally everywhere because it's spelt
the same weather it's on playstation
steam xbox
wherever you can find me and
hopefully we'll get my namesake raid and
that'll be amazing no doubt i'm always
jealous of you death because you can put
your name on everything yeah i'm like
i'm like gaming on steam i'm like lord
added a bunch of numbers on xbox like
it's it's very disturbing dude
that's right you know real quick shout
out to coffee jesus i was in tears in
that stream shaking i've like been
crowbar by sheer or i can't believe
they're doing that stitch five dollar
super chat i got chills when i saw the
galley i got mine a few weeks into the
game from the loot cave thanks for those
glitches gerald mack all hail the iop
salute clearing iop in the building but
philly it seems that bungie was
listening to the last word podcast word
hey they did it all look this is fire
y'all we see y'all in a minute last word
will be on thursday it'll be late and uh
we will see you in a few minutes there's
a lot to talk about yeah oh yeah but we
outta here i'm ending the stream thank
y'all for showing up y'all just don't